[Music]
hey whistle leads here welcome to
winners on a Wednesday this week I am
joined by David Marshall great - ever on
the show David virus yeah there we go
we'll shake canvas oh yeah I saw you
start to move there I thought yeah that
makes sense
so David as I've known you for how long
have I known you now for about that year
probably just a sober yeah yeah okay
brilliant and so let's start from that
from the beginning so before our before
you came on our Academy and came to the
crash cause everything you worked for
Beatty I did yes yeah and tell us a bit
about that well yeah Beatty was a good
job for me I enjoyed working with Beatty
I didn't hate it I actually worked for
Beatty for just under 31 years but yeah
it's because Laura paid the bills and I
was a for I was fairly well paid for the
job I did sir so you were fairly well
paid yeah fairly happy I was I was
content I was no didn't really hanker
for getting in another job or I hate
this job I like to work with Beatty so I
enjoyed it so what made you think
property what what made what what
stirred it up we need to get into
property what sturdy okay basically I
mean the term I was an accidental ended
so I did actually buy my first ask quite
a long time ago I bought it like around
23 25 years ago okay but after couple
years I can actually afford to stay in
there so I you know I had sensitive not
to select so but I want to keep it was
so I just rented it out yeah did you buy
another one or did you just rent where
you lived
no I just I just rented that house I
think I moved back I must move back in
with my family okay I did that but I
just rented this house and I just got an
income from it I in the force was I I
wish I had money to buy another Warren
because that was the only thinking of
had money or all thought I would buy
another house of him but
I didn't and I didn't really try to find
out how to do it so I just think that
the one house so you had one so although
you were a landlord in many ways you in
the same position as most people you own
one house you were slowly paying off the
mortgage you're working at a job that
you reasonably enjoyed the you
everything about paid for and then
beginning of 2018 suddenly you were like
right bang got the property bug and you
wanted to you wanted to sort of start
taking this seriously
okay yeah I mean there was a so I got
introduced and someone someone can ID
showed me and highlighted me what people
were actually doing with 40 and how they
could get multiple properties hmm
and I thought I could give this a girl
and just see what I could do yeah and
that's really been my attitude was it
really he's just the skipper good girl
let's see what I can do
so when you started how did you how did
you feel when you we're excited were you
scared with what we what were you
feeling at that time when you suddenly
made a decision you you were gonna
really get into it I don't figure was no
figures scared when I think was I
excited
I don't really know fell over the cost
excited but what I just I've fought this
again
this is gonna be a good thing if he
works and I you know I should be out I
should become in time like welfare and
the Fords are being scared about it I
love in that cross my mind I've already
bought a house or they're gone for the
process so I don't think there's any
great apprehension I'm so awful yeah
just though it's a positive thing let's
just let's go for it and see what
happens
he came on the crash course early 2018
yeah did you feel inspired I did I know
about what sound like it's saying I hope
this stuff is easy and I believed it
yeah actually and you know because it's
not like a degree you spend four years
to learn something you can do this and
be financially free in six months yeah
you know so you don't need to study for
a whole four years
to get an income or you know how to get
great results you know quite frankly I
mean actually joining the crash course I
I already had through other means
already had like five deals on the girl
so I was fairly confident that I would
be in a couple of months I'll be
financially free yeah FB deals like
comfrey but I'll be fine as you're very
sorry
and then what I'm learning a call
somebody you know we you know give me
much even Baddeley yeah so so you got
five deals that are all going through
yeah five deals while going for it what
what happened to those happen to them
but or baked at least forward them fell
through so I had five deals and forward
and fell through and I think one give
her fifth one I just gave up because
just taking too long to complete I just
understand some basic lost all five
deals and I was in I was in like I'd
there's probably started probably in
january/february yeah so just before
stein the cause I had them but they all
fell for so how did you fail because
obviously you just put on the crash door
she thought this is easy I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna become financially free
to have all the deals for whatever
reason fall out of bed and and you're
left with nothing
how did that make you feel well a very
disparate and persuade I mean and but
what was kind of like evident or when
seeing people and hearing Samuel and I
and forgive yourself I said it but you
just abstain consistent and persisting
things and just keep doing things over
no because you just don't know when you
the the results will start coming either
you know it's just like bus and
sometimes noncoms now comes in and then
all of a sudden you get two or four in a
row and he just stay consistent they
doing the right things and out for other
state this stuff works
other state keep doing it and eventually
I'll get my deal so you had faith it
would come good yeah I I firmly be Ida
property law so I knew is is a good
thing to do so just they you know cousin
doing it I can remember because
obviously you joined our Academy and I
remember I remember meeting you at the
courses and at first you were telling me
about the five deals and then I was like
and you are one of them's falling out of
bed or two and then it was like you a
lot I don't have any deals right now and
I was felt really bad for you because
you're one of those people who you
clearly a consistently good at putting
putting you all into it yeah I really
hope he doesn't get disheartened because
he's come to the events he's doing all
the right things yeah I remember talking
to me a lot I'm doing the calls I'm
doing I'm sending out lease option
agreement letters you were doing
everything you were supposed to be doing
and it felt like everything was going
wrong for you and all the deals falling
out of bed I just thought up I really
hope that he is strong enough yeah to
keep going with this because you know I
think a lot of people at that point we
just got our this doesn't work ah this
is stupid
oh don't invest in property Oh they say
it's it's not Oh but and all this stuff
going on so I think he did really well
I'm really like proud of you there for
like sticking through that something
that shows a lot of character yeah thank
you um it was wet actually one point and
he's one of them dakota calls were
wrecks about on now about six months ago
yeah and he described a hockey stick
curve and you pay all this money you
know gong courses and whatever they're
doing said no you property is he paying
all the money and he's just all this
money's gotten out go now then maybe you
might reach the bottom and then finally
you might get a rental property so you
got earning start earning but you
haven't quite crossed the break-even
point mm-hm so and I thought oh that's
what that's what it is that's what I'm
going through
yeah and I just realized is it's just
the case of
time people just have to stay in the
game and stay long enough that time
period that that hooks the that that
time where you know you pain or all this
money if you couldn't stay in the game
long enough it's gonna shoot up and will
shoot up like hi you just get get up to
that point yeah well you had three first
of all you educated yourself
yeah so you knew what you were doing
then you consistently were doing the
right thing yeah and thirdly you had a
faith and a belief that it would come
good and I think if anyone does that if
anyone you know there'd be a lot of
people probably watching this video that
have tried everything
probably investing with me set up their
own business whatever it is and they'll
have come across hurdles noticed also
for me you are a great example for
anyone like that that you just carry on
doing the right things plugging away and
eventually it was good so tell me about
your your first deal that you've got the
first deal was actually in public August
and it was a relationship that I'd built
up built at Google Asia and they offered
me like a lease option deal so so yeah
the Holy Grail yeah yeah so yeah lease
option deal so I took that maybe started
I did a bit had a good year we food
wasn't quite the way I wanted it so yeah
as for the first one and then two weeks
later they offered me another one Wow
it's funny isn't it often we're like you
say about buses and once you get what
the first deal is always the hardest
yeah how do you how were you buzz in
when the first day know what I got one
yes yeah so yeah I just know you know
that which of brands of fingers well
just know people offer me opportunity I
just take him will say yeah yeah I'm
just got go with it yeah and then soon I
load more deals followed so like we know
six months after that and you're now
officially financially free you just
tell it you you just said to me I'm not
sure if I'm finally free I'm only 31
thousand pound passive income a year but
my expense you know I'm like dude you've
quit your job when do you
job okay Joe in November 18 in
November's you've been there 31 years
you've been in this guy it feels like a
long time
wait minutes going on yeah realistically
it's eight eight months really yeah and
you and before you got your first deal
yeah which in the grand scheme of things
yeah thing is that it's nothing you know
people for you know do it a year long
maybe your long mentorship and you know
you know so you know it happens yeah and
you hear that story you just you know
believed in it have faith in what people
are saying you know do it more
experienced than you so there where
every the stand again yeah this stuff
works so you need to stay in it keep
doing it you get the results yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you're 31,000 Pam passive
income coming in now tell us about some
of the deals that you've got coming up
because I know you I know you're not
resting on your laurels and just think
it huh
I've got 31 grand that's more than the
average wage I can just sit back you're
still plowing on with other stuff so
what you got going through at the moment
so I'm hoping to complete all right
again due next week Tim bed same time 10
bed HMO yeah HMO and quite a large one
yeah it was an opportunity someone
offered me
I didn't say that's it well so yeah
we've made midsize HMOs do them and then
someone offers you another one
well you've got the experience now with
the other ones so that makes sense so
that was that and there we go where's
that that seemed Bradford actually that
was I was listening to Samuels YouTube
Yankees ago and he said one of the areas
are gonna get he was up there so I just
followed it might be under swin found a
property yeah well you very much keep
yourself in the game don't you yeah I do
that I know my activity is high so you
know I do I do a lot and you know what
even while I was working at BT I would
still do one reason I was still doing a
lot activity and I was we
why you know decided to leave because
I'm getting all this results and I'm
still working bTW hmm why am I still
working why do I need to still be
working out to be much more effective
I [ __ ] did this Walter yeah so it was
it's not brand to me it's a much more
effective you know so when you're
working at BT how many hours a week we
spending on your property business oh I
need free free time and if he because I
was up IT support this hour also any
free time I'm any free time I'll do
something make phone calls
lunch breaks and if we time I had my for
minimum probably I would be doing maybe
you know I could probably do at least
and working on what we could do alone at
least half an hour day easily yeah I
would hate that
some days I won't be able to get more
out of a day as we work on the weekends
as well no I just worked one of the
Friday so it was like on the weekends
when I do viewing yeah so I'll do
viewing so my viewings were probably
every not every weekend but probably
probably an to do viewings probably
maybe two or three out of four see what
it wasn't like a massive amount of time
seven hours a week yeah yeah so you
built that up slowly you spend a lot
more time on it now or no because
digital fancy-free now and you're just
living it up yeah because I've made a
point and I have all this I know the
money will come - yeah I'm - you but
it's just the time I want really yes and
just to be able to live the way I want
to
so when I left bTW I didn't want to go
do pop see and do viewings five days a
week or seven days a week I don't want
to do that I don't want to turn it into
another job yeah so
at this I kind of want the time and
freedom to obviously to build up to meet
people meet coffees so I'll probably
have around two days where am I going
you do hearings the other two days were
probably on my leave kind of afraid to
meet up with people also I've got no
time now to do courses what I want to I
don't have to do I haven't got enough
leave so I can do a course if for one of
the course I can just do it yeah so and
you know so I space up my day and it's a
clue for that reason I don't want to
make it a full-time job
yeah I think a lot of people would find
that sort of lifestyle very attractive
yeah it is so is that why you
I mean what's what was the driving
factor because obviously you get the
easy thing to do would have been just to
stay at BT you've been there for years
yeah you used to it and I was going to
do that so what was the what was the
mode I mean that you're now financially
free which is amazing high five for that
by the way what was the what was the
motivation to become financially free
what was your thing I've got two young
children 16 and 15 and I just want to
make sure I don't want them to live to
spend working 40 hours a week for 40
years in the job I just want to show
them there is another way to live
yeah and educate yourself see the world
you know help others if you can do and
you can do that through you know if you
choose to do fruit pops Ian and no for
the passive income you could do for that
way you don't have to be working like 40
hours a week to do that so as much
anything to be an inspiration to your
kids yes the shoulder there was a
different way to live and you have to be
you know yeah that's also and you give
me inspirations lots people watching
this as well well I hope so yeah
so what's what's the plans for you now
then you know what's the what's your
plans for the future completely on these
deals yeah and
I think I'll just keep on there I mean I
don't want to get well I don't say I
don't want to but I can't say I won't
get into developments mm-hmm
because someone if someone's offering
opportunity I'll probably say yesterday
yeah and yeah obviously I'll see if I
can do if for God the ability to do it
but I don't think ad bellum wouldn't
necessarily scare me of it hmm and I
would seek to get the guidance and see
to find out from people what I need to
do what don't need to look at but I'll
probably say yes to it yeah and just go
over it but yet there's no Platt that
there's there's no plan for me to get a
timber hitch ma where he just came up so
there's no plans for you to get big
developments but you might come up what
would you say then looking back at the
last it's not even mean that long is it
2018 last year and a few months or a
year and a half or whatever what would
you say if you just look at that is the
biggest lesson that you've learned okay
I mean obviously I listen to a lot
audiobooks and Napoleon Hill things go
rich and the slight edge mmm
doing little things daily mm-hmm and
that compound effect just daily building
up when he turn around and look after
six months you've done you've done a
hell of a lot he's just like last year
looking back what I did I just I
wouldn't have believed or would have
done it but I was doing a point at work
I was doing Suffolk every day I was
doing so forget every day in property
and whether it's gonna have you ins
worry its phone a solicitor contact it
keep it social more builders or I was
doing something every day yeah and you
know 15 minutes 20 minutes phone calls
you know
so just daily activity where keep doing
it every day if it's only small what
it's a slight edge
and compound effects Darren Hardy
compound effect isn't it I believe was
that for you yes wonder boy Jeff also
Jeff awesome they're not know of great
yeah I've read both of them just keep
doing dead activity and be on the
lookout for opportunities that's right
and don't opportunities everywhere yeah
yeah and you've obviously taken them
with with both hands yeah yeah
absolutely pleasure getting over the
last 18 months I'm really proud as well
well what you've achieved getting to
know you through that and all in a bit
of part of that but look you've been
awesome man again good luck thank you my
name is Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them but what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my two day crash course so if you
would like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week